and look at the camera nice there you go
okay there we go
cardi b and offset's daughter culture is
here to slay the holidays
the i like it rapper shared this
adorable video on twitter of the
three-year-old posing in front of three
large christmas trees during their
family photo shoots and it's no surprise
that she is a natural in front of the
camera just like her mama cardi even
captioned the video quote so much like
me
beautiful
you wanna put your hands on yours like
that again
nice
the mom of two also shared this cute
photo of culture with her sister khalia
offset's daughter from a previous
relationship the girls are matching in
red dresses with bows in their hair yup
just looking cute as ever oh yes honey
but that's not all the cuteness we got
cardi also gave a rare glimpse of her
and offset's newborn son while showing
off her extravagant christmas decor
this year we went with well officer
suggested he wanted a nice christmas
vibe
ready
now there's been lots to celebrate in
the cephas household this holiday season
just last week the grammy winner
celebrated offset's 30th birthday with
the party where she gave him a generous
gift
like really really generous
so babe this is my birthday to you i
know you got a lot of business ventures
coming in 2022 so
let's get
it again
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
yup that right there is the migos rapper
smiling ear to ear after receiving his
big surprise big big things on the way
big bangs on his birthday december 14th
cardi shared a sweet tribute praising
her man alongside a cute video of him
with culture what talking to you
ah my face is big
she also gave fans another look at their
newborn son in the hospital whose name
they have yet to reveal
but offset being a standout dad is
nothing new especially for cardi who
couldn't help but gush to e.t about his
parenting skills back in 2018. he
already has three kids so i already fell
in love
the way that he was a dad already i'm
like oh my god i can have a little one
with this guy he's really good he's
really good
[Music]
you